hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
august 24th 2020 what is going on
and how are you how is it going people
you know it's getting towards the end of
the summer right it's one of the last
weekends where you can wear your white
on white
do you think that's going to move with
global warming is that an idea i
discussed before i don't know
i woke up this morning and for some
reason i had filthy sinatra
songs in my head you know which is
basically
frank sinatra songs but you can't
remember the words so you know
if you're ignorant like me just throwing
curse words to
i just been walking around my house just
singing like come fly with me
you big fat [ __ ] [ __ ]
and if you stew something else and you
[ __ ] snore then i'm kicking you
out of my suite because it's the 1960s
and i'm running [ __ ] [ __ ]
come fly with me you're weighing down
the plane
something like that my wife's going what
the [ __ ] are you you say what's yours
what are you saying that children
i was like i am singing from america's
songbook
all right america's songbook
some of the classics um anyways how's
everybody doing i had a
wonderful relaxing weekend i uh i did
the camp chappelle thing this past
weekend
out in yellow springs ohio and uh i had
an amazing time
got out there wednesday brought the
whole family
um got tested before i got on the plane
got tested afterward
you know went out wednesday i wasn't
even supposed to be on the show jumped
on that show
and um i just had a great time it was
such an amazing
mix of uh
just comedians rappers
poets musicians the whole thing and i
just felt like everybody was sort of
pushing each other
um and uh yeah
and i saw this rapper i'm gonna re-post
uh whatever whatever the hell the kids
do the hashtag with the with the at
symbol
um incredible rapper um
and i was glad i did not have to go on
after him
i am white enough i don't need to be
following that's
that level of heat um just had a great
time and i really want to thank dave he
was so
ridiculously generous to myself my
family everybody
involved and it was so much fun to be
doing stand-up getting laughs and
there was like no phones everybody's
phone was locked
and um it was a level of freedom and
stand-up
that i have not felt since white female
comedians have started complaining
i actually felt like as an american i
could go on stage
and say whatever i wanted
which i remember fondly oh by all the
way back last time maybe six
seven years ago then all of a sudden all
these put upon white females
it's so hard to be a white woman in the
united states of america all of a sudden
i don't know what happened
you know we need to make this fairer and
in the process of them making stand up
fairer i am now
not allowed to say whatever it is i want
to say
this is progressive people
fellow comics censoring
and making you afraid to say what you
want to say on stage i don't i don't get
it
but that's what it is that's what it is
and now what's funny
is now they're experiencing what they
created and now they're tweeting that
they're afraid
to tweet it's the funniest [ __ ] it's
like you helped
build this [ __ ] house of horrors now
you're gonna walk away i always use the
rollerblade analogy
it always works rollerblading we all did
it one homophobic joke
everybody walks away and act like they
never did it and the ocean's just
littered with all of our sins
um i just had a great
great time smoked a few too many cigars
out here
and i really just saw like you know i
really have to address
the ignorance i think the ignorance of
flyover states
is is you know always talked about not
saying there's not ignorance out there
of course there is
of course is you got a bunch of people
talking about a bunch of people that
aren't even anywhere near them
you know the usual [ __ ] and then people
on the coast they talk down to the
people
you know calling flyover states flyover
states you've never spent a week in one
um i'm gonna tell you right now haven't
been out here in ohio
the level of fun that you can [ __ ]
have and the
space and the fresh air
i saw a [ __ ] guy he had a pickup
truck with the camper shell on the back
towing a [ __ ] uh a motorhome
the one you have to tow it's not a
motorhome
no motor but it's a home a home on
wheels
trailer and then behind that he had a
fishing boat
and it's just like there's nowhere way
in l.a you could ha
where the [ __ ] that would take up half
of your property
you know motorcycles four-wheelers um
i mean all just all kinds of just old
cars and [ __ ] like all i could think
about here is if i was out here
i would have a motorcycle i could drive
my you know my f-100
all over the place cruising these
[ __ ] great country roads not sitting
in traffic
beautiful lakes and rivers i mean i'm
sold and i was like man dave
is doing it right this is it's friggin
paradise out here and then we went
one day i took um
my wife and kids and uh we went out to
this place
uh what the hell was it called
it was like it was jersey something or
other
some sort of ice cream place and jersey
i guess is the kind of cow i had no idea
and we went out to this place and the
the friggin ice cream was so good and so
fresh it was like
it was like heroin that then you took
them i got a milkshake this is what i
did i got a vanilla milkshake and i know
you're thinking like oh
jesus bill could you be any whiter
with your plain jane um
order there flavor so this is well this
is what i do
okay this is my thing if i'm going to a
new pizza place
and i want to see if they know what the
[ __ ] they're doing i order a margarita
because anybody you can hide behind your
toppings if you don't quite know how to
make a pizza and it can bump up the
number a little bit
so i always just get the plain
margarita right you got dough you got
sauce you got the cheese
and whatever the [ __ ] else you know a
little olive oil on the top
whatever the hell it is you do right um
and then when i go to an
ice cream place i order vanilla the
plainest
of the flavors arguably um
and if you can make that taste
unbelievable then i know that you guys
know what the hell you're doing and let
me tell you something they passed my
little test there
so uh we did that we got to see some
live
music um quest love and a bunch of other
amazing musicians just playing in the
back of this antique store
it was incredible um
i feel like it's a little comedy
festival out here took me back to the
i feel like you know what it felt like
it felt like i was in aspen
except it was the summer time um
just running into people you know i'm
gonna go down the street running you
just run into somebody and all of a
sudden you know
you guys are grabbing a coffee not like
i'm a big time coffee drinker but uh
every once in a while i'll have one
and i [ __ ] up my order i ordered a i
think a cappuccino
and what i wanted was an espresso that's
what i like just have because i don't
like the really the taste of coffee
so i just try to do the shot and
people's like well that's got more
[ __ ]
caffeine in it it's like all right well
whatever
it's easier you know if you
i don't have to drink a giant one you
know that's one of the smartest things i
ever did was i never got into coffee
you know the amount of time can you
imagine if you were
really into coffee and you were into
sports
and you have to sleep eight hours a day
i mean there goes your whole life that
is your whole [ __ ] life
watching sports standing in line for
coffee and then sleeping
all of a sudden your kid's 36 you never
even played catch with them
um anyway i'm just [ __ ] around here
uh
i have been you know i didn't get a
chance to watch
a lot of the playoffs i'm back here in
l.a now so uh
very excited to uh get caught up since i
stopped watching
my boston bruins closed out for the
second year in a row
the carolina hurricanes um
and i looked at that like that was sort
of the rubber match there
series where i remember
oh god how many years ago like 10 years
ago
you know they ended up uh we played them
in like the eastern conference finals
and they want like the overtime game and
that guy did the jazz hands skating down
the [ __ ] ice
they beat us and then last year we beat
them so
you know this is the one to see who's
ahead i think i i would think
um what else happened oh you're
philadelphia flyers your number one seed
the odds-on favorite
to go to the stanley cup is it final or
finals
i always forget but i looked them both
up they're both nba
and stanley cup are written as finals
for some reason i thought one was the
nba final
or the stanley cup final i forget and
people always say uh there's only one
final ever there's seven games
that would be the finals you're playing
in the final you're playing
seven games the finals it totally makes
sense to me
i like when people do that [ __ ] you know
they try to sit there and think they're
so [ __ ]
why is it called football all those
douches who watch soccer
why is it called football well they kick
it off kicking's a huge part of the
[ __ ] game
[ __ ] patriots won three super bowls
kicking field goals
all right why don't you brush your teeth
and watch the [ __ ] game
sorry um
anyway uh the flyers
beat the hated habs jesus christ
27 years 28 seasons
unbelievable i just remember as a kid
that the new york rangers were
considered curse and they cursed and
they went 54 years
and the montreal canadiens are now
halfway there half
way there i was 25 years old the last
time they won it
25 years old i'm now a 52 year old man
well there's best years behind them
so speaking of which 1993 was also the
last time
that uh a canadian team won the stanley
cup
and uh you know it's ridiculously in
favor
of uh the united states considering
there's like 30 teams and what do you
got you got the canadians the senators
the maple leafs the jets
calgary edmonton vancouver you got seven
teams
you know and we got 23.
it's [ __ ] hilarious because some
americans talk [ __ ] to canadians about
that stuff and it's just like how many
americans are playing on those
american nhl teams well all right then
um
so anyway uh vancouver canucks
uh the last the lone canadian team left
and they knocked out your
saint louis blues making me
have to say that i don't know what i'm
talking about
i thought that blues team once they once
they tied it up or whatever they want to
come back
i think they tied it up but once they
won game three then i came out to uh
yellow springs ohio and i kind of lost
track of the series i was watching the
uh i check out the scores but i was
working every night
um congratulations to them beating a
very very tough team
uh the saint louis blues uh but then
they got their
vancouver got their evidently got mopped
they the knights mopped the floor with
them last night five
nothing i gotta tell you man i don't
know i don't know what it is the knights
came
out that first year and damn near won it
who'd they lose to the capitals
i believe in six or seven i can't
remember what
um but i would think that they'd still
have the core of that team
left and everybody's uh you know
all those philly fans are talking all
this [ __ ] about the flyers and
everybody's just kind of sleeping on the
vegas nights i feel
or maybe i haven't been paying attention
and they aren't now speaking of philly
what happened to those 76ers
the boston celtics going down there
everybody's excited remember those early
80s series
those great [ __ ] wars that the
celtics had with the 76ers
celtics were down 3-1 came back and beat
the sixers and then that next year we
were down 3-1
and julius jams jinx i'll never forget
that on the cover of sports illustrated
then one of the greatest teams of all
time that i would put up against the 96
bulls the 1983
uh philadelphia 76ers i was hoping it
was going to be a great series
uh this definitely was not philly's year
celtics sweep them
take out the brumps swept them under the
liberty belt
rocky fell halfway up the steps
on his with his gray on grays um
yeah so we shall see but still the
number one seed from
cream thickel from cream town cream city
is the milwaukee bucks uh i'm actually a
big fan of that franchise
just when i was younger you know sydney
moncrief and all those guys they were
always a tough team
and uh it was still you know within 10
years
of lual cinder if he wasn't kareem at
that point leading them to their
one and only championship 1971
and uh so i always liked those guys uh
they all said green in their uniforms
and [ __ ] and they weren't the 76ers and
they weren't the lakers so i only had so
much hate in my heart i had to be
i'd be like you know i like i like
milwaukee and they swept the uh the
celtics one year
there was the last year bill fitch being
uh the cor
the the head coach of the celtics
um what year was that that might have
been 83
i can't remember um all right
so yeah so i was out here
and they had a great setup for doing
like the stand-up and everything
and just with the total freedom to know
that i wasn't going to get in trouble
for anything that i said that i i mean
it's some of the best sets
i had and um
i i don't know it was awesome and then
it also made me sad thinking like this
is how stand-up used to be there used to
be so much
fun where you could just like
just empty your brain and say the
craziest [ __ ]
you know digging holes trying to get out
of it [ __ ] with people
being absurd all of that stuff and it's
just really just sort of been uh
i don't know remember when clear channel
ruined radio
i feel like that's been done to stand up
and it made me want to
uh
i don't know just go back to the way i
used to do it when i was on stage
because i don't think that i
i just slowly you know
i gave ground i feel
and uh so and i realized this week how
much i
do censor myself when i'm on stage and i
think i've been doing it for so long
over the years it's now become this
subconscious thing
don't say that might get in trouble oh
that's not worth that
and what's so funny is you're just
joking around
i don't know i don't know maybe when
white women finally get what it is that
they want
they'll let us have fun again oh
it is funny watching white women call
other white women karen's
i think that's [ __ ] hilarious like
that's the big thing
like once it names sticks then you gotta
act like no but i'm one of the good ones
you know that's like hipsters calling
other hipsters hipsters
um i mean you never hear me calling
somebody else sexist do you
i try to stay in my lane i know what the
[ __ ] i am
um anyway uh
yeah i could not i have a better time
and just being out here
um you know with my kids and everything
and taking them out you know i took my
daughter out and she was feeding these
these goats
and uh down at that farm and um
i mean she's just having the time of her
life from the cows
and they had all kinds of just fun stuff
for them to do
sitting on old tractors and [ __ ] and uh
you know just that that dad stuff that
you get to do
that was a lot of fun and uh and my son
is just like
you know now he's just cooing and
smiling and everything
and uh i know i got some just amazing
amazing pictures
of everybody this past weekend
really needed it recharged my batteries
so i'm going gonna continue to try and
do some shows here
um in and around the la area that
parking lot outside of the magic castle
um everybody stays in their cars people
seem to be safe i'm just gonna go down
there
and uh i don't care how many people
drive away
i'm going to try to hang on to the the
freedom that i had at camp chappelle
um
it's just unbelievable that you that in
america you have to actually
be careful when you're not even being
serious
you're joking around and you have to be
careful it's just the most [ __ ] up
thing
oh people there is so much [ __ ] that i
could say and so many names that i could
say but i would just
never do that i just think comedian on
comedian
[ __ ] attacking this cannibalism just
has to [ __ ] stop
um i don't know so maybe i shouldn't
even joked around
and said white female comics
[Laughter]
it's so hard um
anyway um so yeah
so now i'm back in la i gotta drop a few
pounds that i gained
out there in yellow springs too much ice
cream too much uh
of the local fare out there i found
there's a wonderful uh
store there where they made these these
uh
homemade whatever handmade i guess is
what the word like these
uh lamps that had like the shade is like
glass all these different colors so um
i got one of those from my office you
know spent money in a local business
and um i don't know just had a great
time out here and i was thinking like
you know i would love
to live in a place like this if it was
more accepting
um yeah anyway plowing ahead here let's
do uh
let's do what do we got here
yeah yellow springs always really
liberal it was almost aggressively
liberal how
how the the force with which they were
saying hello to my wife was hilarious
[Laughter]
person of color hello did anybody
film that i knew might need that in the
future this is me
saying hello to a black person um
all right zip
[Music]
uh hiring is challenging
um oh jesus hiring is challenging
especially with everything else you have
to consider today
but there's yeah exactly you have no
idea what people did this person just
come from one of those lake parties
right
bumping and grinding on people gonna
bring the covet into the cubicle area
uh but there's one place you can go
where hiring is simple
fast and smart a place where businesses
can connect to qualified candidates
that place is ziprecruiter.com zip
recruiter sends your job
to over 100 of the web's leading job
sites but they don't stop there
with their powerful matching technology
chip recruiter scans thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
experience
and actively invites them to apply to
your job
ziprecruiter makes the entire hiring
process efficient and effective with
features
like screening questions to filter
candidates and all in one
dashboard where you can review and rate
your candidates i would love to see some
of those questions
uh zip code is so effective that four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get to qualify
uh get a quality candidate within the
first day
there you go it's the kind of results
people can get behind here right now
when you try zip
for free my listeners can go to
ziprecruiter.com
that ziprecruiter.com spell out burr
okay b-u-r-r ziprecruiter.com
one more time zip
the smartest way to hire all right oh
look who's here me and these beyondies
do and stand up in the woods doo doo
doo doo me undies me undies saying
everything i
could there weren't any [ __ ]
in the crowd recording the show
saying your jokes didn't make me proud
to be an american
i know everything cause i have a [ __ ]
clam and i'm white
all right do you have a moose near the
caboose
that needs to be tamed i'm talking hairy
big
and need some support
what in the [ __ ] are they talking about
thankfully our sponsors today
manscape has you covered to keep the
hair
looking nice and trimmed and feeling
fully supported
manscape offers precision engineering
tools for your family jewels
a [ __ ] moose i don't even get that do
you have a
moose near the caboose the caboose is
your ass
i don't know i i don't think that mooses
have this
have a pubic hair [ __ ] look about
them i think that this [ __ ] looks like
it's been relaxed
i don't know maybe i'm too old to get it
okay beluga
did you hear that that's your moose
asking for manscaped
the manscape engineering team just
perfected the greatest
ball hair trimmer uh ever created
are they saying the front of a moose's
face looks like a hairy bald bag
is that what this i don't know the
lawnmower 3.0 the premium lawnmower 3.0
is waterproof
includes an led light that means you can
shave in the shower with the lights off
you [ __ ] weirdo
and is made with advanced skin safe tm
technology which reduces nicks and cuts
on your delicates um
you can get this trimmer inside the
perfect package 3.0
which also includes the manscape crop
preserver
ball deodorant and the crop reviver
bald toning spray it's gonna tone your
balls
smooth out the wrinkles both super
practical
and they smell great too plus for a
limited time when you order the perfect
package kit
you get two free gifts um oh it's two
free gifts
uh the shed travel bag and the manscape
anti-chafing boxer briefs um
how can you get shafe wearing boxer
briefs they [ __ ] hang down right if
you wearing tidy whities i would imagine
the
uh the twins there get a little upset
uh the manscape boxer briefs have
optimal temperature control with their
crop cooling technology while keeping
that means literally they were in
you know the lab there and they had
people put on their underwear and then
afterwards
scientists came back by with a gloveless
hand and cupped their balls
to see which one ball bag ball bag on
the wall
who's got the coolest nuts of them all
it's like a fairy tale with nuts
um anyway pair these boxer priests with
their ph
balancing liquid products like the crop
preserver and
you're ready for anything uh get 20 off
free shipping with the code
burr2o burr20
at manscape.com your balls will thank
you get 20
off and free shipping with the code bur
at manscape.com that's 20 off jesus
christ with free shipping at
manscape.com and use
the code bur 20 from the moose to the
caboose
uh always use the right tools for the
job
i guess they're trying to say that a
moose has a is like a dick face
i just i don't know i don't see it
unless your balls will weigh the [ __ ]
out in front of you like that keep on
trucking
drawing right all right let's get into
some of the uh
some of the answers here no the
questions here
and i guess then eventually we're
getting to some of the answers um i know
i'm behind on motogp everybody i think
of davitziosa won the previous race i
didn't see today's race
uh or yesterday's race i should say i
gotta get caught up like i said i was
out here doing family [ __ ]
um all right thank you uh dear bill
i'm a 25 year old male from seattle and
a big fan of your comedy and podcast
well thank you
this might sound sappy but i didn't have
great dad parentheses dads
growing up from abusive alcoholics
to full-blown sociopaths well
no offense to your mom but jesus christ
she could really pick him huh
uh there was nobody to show me how to be
a man
i like what you do because you explain
how you feel about something
even if it's not healthy and then
provide how you would
or should actually deal with it
oh yeah because yeah cause i'm a [ __ ]
mess dude
i need to talk it out when it comes to
uh
when it comes to the old emotions there
um by listening to your perspective on
things i can relate to what you're
saying without feeling like
some monster and i've been able to make
positive changes in my life
i deal with my anger better i don't have
sex with hookers anymore
well jesus christ there's two huge
improvements
and i feel like i can be honest with
myself and others because my issues
aren't all that extreme or different i
want you to know that your work has
changed my life for the better
thank you jesus christ i'm gonna save
that someday foreign
if and when i get in trouble for telling
knock knock jokes there
yeah i'll tell you the big thing i did
was i told my wife i needed
her help with my anger um
she still hasn't really done it um
but i think that she just she's so used
to going to some place mentally when i
start flipping out that it's gonna take
her a while
to uh you know
my daughter's perfect you know second i
start to lose it she'll be like
she's just in the other room she's like
don't scream like that
i immediately gonna go sorry buddy
you're right
you know go in there give her a hug
daddy was screaming
dad why why you scream
it's just no logical answer especially
when i think about what i'm yelling
about so
um i think you know
it really helps the woman in your life
if you
admit to your problem you address it you
get it out there and say that you need
help
and then you tell her that this isn't dr
phil where he just you just say this
[ __ ] once and then i walk away and it's
perceived that the problem has been
fixed
i'm gonna have a long time to do this
you know and then hopefully
if you're with a mature woman which
they're not easy to find
okay there's all of this [ __ ] out there
that you know just blows women
you know and says how [ __ ] amazing
they are and all this like they don't
have any [ __ ] issues but the only
reason why that just comes from the
advertisers
because they know that women emotionally
run the relationship
and they also know that they're going to
manipulate the man into spending way
more money than he should be on whatever
[ __ ] holiday it is so what they do
is they just blow them and say they're
never wrong
you know and blah blah blah blah and
then they just go after the [ __ ] guys
when the reality is is we're both out of
our [ __ ] minds and we need each other
you know to help one another so we we
don't
go crazier right i don't know
that's what i would think all right
zimbabwean fan
look at this i think i'm gonna go play
the zimbabwe [ __ ] funny bone
uh thanks bill for the standups the
podcast efforts for family
nice the ridiculously funny late night
interviews
and everything in between by the way i
wrote all these emails this week
my friends and i absolutely enjoy your
politically incorrect [ __ ] it's a shame
you've never performed in my country
but i hope i'll visit yours one day if
this corona crap dies down
uh then attend one of your shows and
hackle he says it's heckle h-e-c-k-l-e
not ace
all right heckle you mercilessly just to
get on your last nerve keep on
chimder chimdara can mean sick old man
oh keep on shindara chandara bird
chandara can mean sick old man
uh my in my shona language thanks man
chin dog chimdara sorry
no wait my eyes are going yeah that
isn't him chimdara
all right look at that now wait a minute
zimbabwe you guys weren't the ones with
those crazy [ __ ] things that you guys
were blowing during the
uh the the the world cup
about 10 years ago those huh
sounded like jim carrey and [ __ ] uh
dumb and dumber remember when he said
you wanna hear the most annoying sound
ever
that's what those things sounded like um
listen i would love to go to africa at
some point you know what i mean and at
some point would mean uh
the point where you know what all the
white people did over there
is over
[Laughter]
i used to do a bit about that how as a
white dude you got to really be careful
you know that when i traveled i liked
going to white countries because there
was going to be white people there
because
the second you went latino african or
anything like that no i never went to
africa but whatever
it's just like you know that you have to
look up okay
what did white people do here because
you're gonna get you know
and i remember i went to um
costa rica and rather than reading up on
it i just sort of like did a little
you know thought about it even though i
didn't know [ __ ] about central america
i was like all right that was the
conquistadors
they were from spain okay and in my head
spanish people were latino rather than
thinking no they're european they speak
spanish and through all these years
white people have been saying mexicans
speak spanish
you know what i mean i don't know so
there's all of that
and then that's why like when i go to
europe or whatever i'm watching the news
in spanish and i've seen a blond-haired
woman
speaking spanish going wait a minute
what the [ __ ] going on i
i haven't read up on any of that so
there's all kinds of crazy [ __ ] so
i didn't know any of that [ __ ] so i was
thinking it was the conquistadors
you know those latino people from europe
that's literally what i was thinking so
i go that wasn't white people
[Music]
so um i [ __ ] go there and i'm getting
all these dirty looks and i'm like what
the [ __ ]
so i'm thinking all right there's got to
be some sort of economic sanctions
there's got to be something that we did
here
we must have our military must have
helped
you know the guy that was going to help
the corporations and not the people the
usual [ __ ]
and what i basically what i found is
where i was staying dole and chiquita
banana had farms there that they had
that they had somehow purchased and they
just bought up all the land
from the local farmers and the farmers
had to stay
working on their former farms or
something
i forget how it went down and they
weren't getting paid
[ __ ] and chiquita and dole were taking
all the [ __ ] money and then my
dumbass shows up with like a snorkel and
a brochure like hello everybody
and i got all these guys down there with
[ __ ] machetes
sitting there looking at me it's very
uncomfortable
uh having said that costa rica is
beautiful
you know those howler monkeys oh my god
[ __ ] things were crazy but i just if
you're just into
like i don't know i took a zipline tour
through i was basically at the the very
top of the rain forest
and uh i have to be honest with you it's
something that i would not do
uh nowadays i did it then but i would
not do it now
because i just that [ __ ] story of
those two
women who were gonna go into the
rainforest
and decided to go in themselves and then
they got [ __ ] lost
is just the [ __ ]
scariest goddamn [ __ ] thing i can
ever even think of
um one of one of the scariest things so
uh
i guess because it's a zipline tour like
i would be
i would just be like with a guide the
entire friggin way
um anyway plowing ahead so zimbabwe
you know somebody was asking me he's
like have you ever gone
on a on a safari like in africa i was
like no i haven't and i just i don't
know
i uh i look at those animals the same
way i look at celebrities you know what
i mean
it's just like i don't want to bother
them
[Laughter]
you know they've been through enough
okay they they just
just they can't even just [ __ ] they
can't even [ __ ] and there's somebody
taking a
picture of them making a [ __ ] movie
same thing happens to celebrities
that's why it's always funny to me where
you know when when they show like some
of these [ __ ] celebrities houses
right they'll be like hey he's got his
own bowling alley he's got his own movie
theater it's like
yeah because he has to or she has to
they can't [ __ ] go anywhere
everybody's up their ass and then if
they get like aggravated after a while
then the video just shows them like look
at him beat a dick to his fans
that's the last time i go to see
backdraft
[ __ ] fast and the furious or whatever
the [ __ ] it is
um anyway um
yeah so as far as that like i
love animals but like i also really
respect them and i just
i just don't want to go i just don't
want to be another [ __ ] in a jeep
driving by you know
just being where that's you know we
already took enough of their [ __ ]
land can they just chill out and
kill an ostrich or whatever the hell
they're supposed to be doing
um
i don't know but it would be fascinating
like i really like like especially all
of the african animals mean how do you
not love
lions and leopards leopards i love a
leopard you gotta love a leopard
cheetahs sort of a anorexic leopard
of course you got your elephant pack of
doings um
hippos are rhinoceroses i love when they
go on i love when they go at it you know
a couple of fatties get in the ring
you know when the big thing what always
ends up happening is somehow
you know the rhino wants to get the
hippo perpendicular
you know hit him broadside him
like the [ __ ] rhino blew a red light
right as the hippo was coming in the
intersection and once he gets that
[ __ ] hippo
sideways that is [ __ ] it
it is a wrap um
and also i just think that those lions
are getting less and less
afraid of the cars
and they they're stop there's that whole
thing where like you can sit there
because the
the lion views you as part of
the car or the jeep and i think they're
starting to separate it like i said
i saw a [ __ ] bear open a car door
kick open a door like the [ __ ] feds
they can ride bicycles
you know it's nature they're going to
start learning
to survive somebody's going to get
snatched
and guess what it's not going to be me
um
having said that you know i don't know
oh my god and then forget about all the
reptiles and [ __ ] reptiles are just like
just they are the sociopaths of the
[ __ ] um
of the animal world they they just they
don't give a [ __ ] komodo dragons
they're just i mean just heartless
you know i don't know there's something
about a mammal maybe because i relate to
it
um although i do have about as much hair
as a lizard all right
east india trading company hey billy boy
hey there billy boy hey there freckles
um you mentioned the east india company
and said you don't know much
about them all right yes i did
i already forget what they are i i
attached a quick video about them to sum
them up
but they were essentially an extension
of the empire's government
they pretty much did the normal uh the
normal of what white people
would do to us third world people back
then
genocide looting slavery all the hits
they stole 45 trillion worth of wealth
from india india accounted for a quarter
of the world's
uh gdp what is that gross something
product
forget uh before the white man got there
well why can't you question why didn't
you kick their [ __ ] ass
you had all of those goddamn people it
was a [ __ ] home game
i mean that's just [ __ ] hardcore like
you guys were just crushing it and then
they just come in like yeah we're just
gonna take that
uh when they left it was only two
percent
yeah i know i don't think that there's
enough out there there seems to be
plenty out there about what the nazis
did to the jews there's plenty out there
about what white people did to african
americans
but uh or maybe i just haven't been
paying attention to this jesus christ
white people white people you don't have
to do
it um they stole 45 trillion worth of
the wealth from india
india accounted for a quarter okay
already said that when they left it was
only two percent
to put the 45 trillion into context
the gdp of america is 20 trillion
they stole more than double what the
entire american economy generates an
entire year from my people
good thing gandhi sent their cracker
asses home
uh then about 60 years later you just
imported all of us because apparently
you guys suck at being doctors
and tech things oh look at you talking
[ __ ] look at you talk last i checked you
guys don't have polio because of us
you know i was on board i get it you got
to talk a little bit of [ __ ]
listen this is what this is the deal
there's smart people and there's evil
people
there's geniuses and there's [ __ ]
dopes everywhere that's why racism is so
stupid so the bottom line is as bad as
those english guys were
those people exist in your country of
india too
all right i've been over there with your
t-shirts real men don't rape
stop acting like you guys are a bunch of
saints over there i'm not saying you're
bad people i'm just saying like every
country
you got your good in the bed you know
they got this thing now you know
they point that thing in your forehead
to see if you have a temperature
they got to do that with like human
beings you know to see if you're a
psycho or not
you know but the problem is is that
psychos run the corporations so then
what they would do is they would just
use that [ __ ]
to take out nice people
you know like i was talking to a buddy
of mine one time and i was saying
talking about power house
psychos are attracted to power and nice
people
they they're just not they're not
attracted to it so what ends up
happening is nice people end up working
for like psychos and then psychos stay
in power
by killing loud nice people
that's basically it so even if you came
up with that invention
the way that they have all of science
under their corporate umbrellas
um they would make sure that they passed
the test
um so i don't know um
and no we do not suck at being doctors
any more than you guys suck at whatever
white people have said you guys suck at
everybody is you know
offers something and everybody has
people in their society that need to be
removed
um all right let's plow ahead here
all right need advice on my parents
um i would love to get in because you
know what i actually i know that dude
was just [ __ ] around because
i went over to india and they are some
of the biggest [ __ ] ball breakers
i've ever met in my life
absolutely hilarious people they're
right up there with like the irish
scottish people as far as like
places i went outside of my country
where people were just giving me [ __ ]
um i told you i remember the comics i
met over there they were trying to hey
you should talk about this on stage take
you talk about that on stage i was doing
that podcast and then i was like wait do
you guys talk about this on stage and
they started laughing they were trying
to get me in trouble over there
um it was like some comedy seller [ __ ]
on the other side of the planet
so anyway all right plowing ahead here
need advice on my
parents oh geez oh wait a minute you
know what i love when people say i need
advice because that gives me a chance
to play my little jingle
[Music]
hey
all right let's get back to it here
um need advice on my parents
oh
sorry just goes into the uh
the playlist there all right um
shut that off okay need advice on my
parents hello
billy badass uh first of all
i'm a huge fan look at all these
compliments this week i usually get
[ __ ] [ __ ]
huge fan of the podcast and all the work
you that you do thank you
even though it was a long time ago i
liked your acting in breaking bad
what the [ __ ] does that mean even though
it was a long time ago
i liked your acting and breaking bad i
guess because when you go back in time
most of the stuff i did sucked i don't
even know what that means anyways
now moving on i am writing today
for advice about my parents i grew up
most of my life in the midwest and moved
to washington dc about a year ago
for work my parents are still living in
the midwest and do not seem
to have much going on these days um okay
it seems like they're getting close to
retiring i'm busy with work most days
and always and i'm always
out and about working out and
socializing with friends
i used to love spending time with my
parents and hanging out with them but
now it seems that whenever they call me
uh they want me to work on something
i've
i feel is dumb and annoying like double
checking my taxes
looking at how my ira is doing going to
uh going to get a corona test even
though i'm as healthy as can be
registering to vote making sure i'm
wearing my mast every day etc
just being parents man it's like they're
asking you for money because they're at
home drinking a jug of wine every night
i feel as though i never want to answer
the phone because it's always negative
news
oh i see okay whenever they do call and
i know it sounds
bad but their calls often ruin my
otherwise good days
since it's gotten so bad lately i have
thought about cutting off my
ties with them jesus christ we do not
think
this is a good situation yeah no don't
do that uh do you have any suggestions
on how to work this out with them i want
to stay in touch with them but their
constant worrying and nagging is driving
me nuts
thanks and have a good day well you need
to communicate that with them
just say mom dad i love you guys to
death thank you for raising me
um i just need to discuss our
relationship
and you just talk about how you feel
that it is in the way that you you would
like it
i would really enjoy if you would just
call up just to say hello
can we just talk about a game um
i understand that i'm always going to be
your baby so you're always going to be
worrying about
me but like my taxes are done i got my
ira
i have i'm wearing a mask i am fine i'm
adult
i know how to take care of myself can
can we please
talk about you know just call up and
hang
shoot the [ __ ] be friends man i would go
you know communication it's always it's
always the best thing and when you
communicate
you got to make sure that you're not
insulting the person
you got to be you can't you know i
learned that you can't just
you can't communicate but i think you
know i just every [ __ ] time you call
me it's just like
what did you do you can't do that
you just have to say you know and
i actually found myself the other day
when you called thinking about not
answering the phone call
which is a major red flag to me because
you're my parents and i love you guys
so we obviously need to clear this part
of our relationship up i think it's an
easy thing
and you know what they're gonna go back
you know they'll be good for a couple
and they'll start to go back and then
you can just be like
dad mom like here we go again
um i think you should do that but you
should never you should never cut your
parents out of your life
all right um unless it's just you know
something
i don't know i don't know i don't want
to discuss
the topics on why you would do that but
for what you're talking about no this is
something that can be worked out
um all right girlfriend wants my mom to
die
i mean i just had to pause there and
take that sentence in
girlfriend wants my mom to die dear
billy blue balls
uh so i've been seeing this lady
for almost six months now well i'll tell
you this right now reading that title if
you
if you see her for seven months uh
you're the worst son ever
we really fit well together and have
grown really close but one thing
is she's got a huge problem with my ma
she thinks my mom is the most evil
selfish person in the world
wait and you already know that six
months in
you gotta pull the rip cord buddy and i
gotta say she's made me realize that my
mom
can be fake and manipulative sometimes
yep and now she's breaking you down
you're gonna have stockholm syndrome
soon you need to get out of this
but she recently said she wishes my mom
was dead
and i just froze i don't wish that at
all i know
she has her problems but like holy tits
that was over the line especially since
she knows that i
really only had my mom when my dad left
us when i was a kid yeah you gotta dump
this this woman's a piece of [ __ ] and
she everything she's accusing your
mother of dude
she's doing to you she's manipulative
and now she's [ __ ] with your brain
and you know what rather than just kind
of going down the field taking two yards
here three yards
she threw the [ __ ] bomb
i wish your mom was dead she went for
the [ __ ] end zone she went for the
kill shot right and
complete was not caught and you just
froze you slapped it out of the [ __ ]
air like a shutdown corner right and now
you know what to do
he goes i don't know oh i don't know
what to do bill i feel like i'm caught
between these two significant people in
my life right now and it's making me
crazy
hopefully you see this and have a nice
[ __ ] day yeah buddy
i mean you're six months in to this
relationship and she just said she
wishes your mother was dead
okay that who she's a [ __ ] psycho
she's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] the woman
you're dating is a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
no one should ever say that 20 years
into a marriage with the worst
mother-in-law
ever i get it i get it
but even then you gotta you gotta i
can't say this this is this person's
bomb the fact that she said that dude
you know judgment for the defendant
you yeah dumper dumper you know what i
mean jesus christ
i mean what in the [ __ ] could she
possibly be doing that would warrant
that statement and this is your
six months in she's supposed to still be
pretending that she's a cool person
you're supposed to still be pretending
that every time for the rest of your
life you're gonna pull the chair out
when she goes to sit down
you know she's just starting to show you
who she is and she said i wish your mom
was dead
just thank you lucky stars that you
didn't [ __ ] marry this chick you
didn't have kids with her and all of
this just because
you know what do you think is going to
happen
eventually if she's not [ __ ] happy in
a relationship with you
and you guys are married you got kids
and your lives are all entangled
and all of a sudden she starts wishing
you were dead
huh and then out of nowhere she wants
to cook for you every night and
everything has an almond aftertaste
yeah get rid of her that is a [ __ ]
it is completely unacceptable
um statement and you're a child of
divorce so you probably don't have the
boundaries that you need to have and
that boundary that is a
a boundary that was crossed and she
cannot cross back over
that is some benedict arnold [ __ ] and
she needs to walk the plank
good day sir um
just my gut feeling all right overrated
slash underrated
underrated having a plan for your
funeral i
100 agree that agree that agree with
that
[ __ ] all right hey billy ballbag
um i was listening to the cast
uh backs on the thursday afternoon
i was listening to the cast back on the
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning
podcasts from last week i've turned 28
last week and i've already known my
funeral plans
down to the finer details for the past
10 years
bit of background i grew up in my
childhood household with my grandmother
a now 93 year old lady
who was brought up in her childhood in
england during world war
ii oh so she's tough as nails morbid
topics like death
since i was young were never far off the
table
so for sure i think we're one of the
minority who can face the ultimate
guarantee in this life
death my friends think i'm weird when i
tell
them if a song has changed
uh that what i what i want played
as the curtains close cremation all the
way i mean in another hundred years
who's coming to see my headstone with
the toothbrush and some bleach
to see my name through the moss and the
weeds
uh anyway or what party song i want
on entrance
to my wake to lighten the mood music
you know what i had a uh relative die
and he picked all the music and it was
really cool
and and he i i
got to see the love that he had
for the woman in his life and his kids
and all that by the
music that he chose i thought it was
really cool so i think this is all cool
entrance to the crematorium uh
elvis presley and american trilogy
i don't think i know that song uh guest
exiting cremation elvis presley if i can
dream
from the nbc 68 comeback special
dude this is the [ __ ] guess entry thing
the wake
the cult she sells sanctuary
this should be a [ __ ] thing dj music
during weight
70s 80s rock motown
cheese room classics only
uh song whilst ashes are scattered over
the snow-filled mountains somewhere in
europe
fleetwood mac landslide uh assets and
will
all my collections of sets set lists
from concerts
sam that's his brother photography
equipment donate to a local college for
students to use
laptop is going to stuart his best
friend
trust him to dispose of anything
inappropriate and keep everything from
my photography traveling the world
carr mazda miata mk3 to his buddy dan
friend who was an absolute petrol head
hoping he would tune it up
in his workshop and enjoy it until he
left it in
a bumping heap on a track on a track day
uh catering fish finger sandwiches and
fries with every sauce from tomato to
brown sauce to suit everyone's unique
acquired taste
long time fan yet to be in the same
country as you at the same time to see
you in person one day
soon when this is all over and done with
uh hope you
the wife and kids stay safe
roll on season five of ephesus for
family
i think that's really cool
you know my wife's been giving me [ __ ]
because i said i wanted to be cremated
she's like no we gotta have burial plots
next to each other so
um i don't know i didn't think i would
oh jesus you got to play highway to hell
when you're [ __ ] lowering in the
coffin into the ground
banana um
yeah i think about that type of stuff i
don't know what i would have i would
just like it to be
a um
like more of a party more of a
celebration of my life and i would also
like
hopefully that i've said all the things
that i need to say certainly i know i've
done it to all
my uh my family i know that
um
yeah that's what you just want to thank
man what a great [ __ ] guy i'm gonna
miss that guy
you know but we had you know so many
great times that's what happened my
buddy wayne passed
you know we were all sad and crying and
all that and then we just started
telling stories and just
laughing our asses off and all the
pictures came in
and it's just him just always being
like the life of the party was just
never a downer so i'm hoping that that
oh jesus never a downer jesus christ
let's let's not get too crazy bill
um yeah i don't know if i'll pass the
never being a downer test my buddy wayne
did though
um so yeah i think i think that's a
great thing to do
um because you do you never know you do
never know
and um i also think that if you
pick it like that and it's really
specific it is sort of this
last this bonus interaction
that they get with you that they know
that these songs
mean this much it's a way for you to
communicate with them
from beyond the grave um
beyond the ashes all right that is the
podcast everybody
uh once again uh thanks to dave
chappelle
and everybody out there that made that
whole thing happen
um it was just an absolute
incredible experience and thank you for
reminding me what
the freedom of st what's the freedom of
stand-up used to be
and um it just really was a nice
cold bucket of water to realize what was
slowly taken away
um for no reason for no reason
and by the left which i am i'm a [ __ ]
lefty
and uh it's just a [ __ ]
it just doesn't make any goddamn sense
it makes no [ __ ] sense
any more than it would it made sense
when the i felt like the right was doing
it right after 9
11. um
not to mention both parties then all of
a sudden they used you know
in an effort to stop terrorism once they
had to do
they then you know you know took away a
lot of rights and [ __ ] it's just i don't
i don't [ __ ] know i don't know
but i just hope we the the ball slowly
stops and starts to roll back towards
the middle
because i don't think at any time
ever in the history the left or the
right has been a hundred percent right
sometimes the left's right sometimes the
right's right that's why if you're in
the middle
and you can listen and take each
situation individually you have i feel
the best
chance of making a rational decision and
even then you got a huge
chance of [ __ ] it up because we're
human beings and we're flawed all right
that's it
all right go [ __ ] yourselves
and i'll check in on you on thursday
you